son objectif est de rassembler la gauche
il ne lui reste plus que le verbe pour
convaincre d'une certaine façon
machiavel dit rien n'est pire en
politique que les trompettes désarmer et
à sa façon madame taubira est un peu
aujourd'hui une prophète désarmés
merci à vous merci pour cette confiance
l ailier cette gauche qui a des
références ses grandes figures qui nous
en montrer qu'effectivement on peut un
peu fidèle à ses valeurs
regardez le réel ces grandes figures
sont celles de jean jaurès celle de léon
gambetta celle de léon blum celle de
pierre mendès france
celle de françois mitterrand ces grandes
figures sont celles de ces femmes ces
hommes qui ont mené des combats
audacieux et des combat d'avant-garde et
là tout fait pour réactiver bayrou
appelé l'illusion lyrique illusion
unique de gauche c'était un discours qui
plongeait ses racines dans l'histoire
des réponses pour garantir une véritable
séparation des pouvoirs des réponses
pour une laïcité qui n'écrase pas mais
émancipe et marcy
là elle est plus ambigu sur la question
de la laïcité
qui est quand même un héritage des
luttes la gauche je rappelle que kavala
droits
concernant la séparation de l'église et
de l'état
porté entre autres par la figure
d'aristide briand là dessus elle
apparaît quand même beaucoup
réserver on voit que le discours qu'elle
porte c'est un discours qui certes veut
s'inscrire dans l'épaisseur du temps
historique de la gauche elle veut porter
l'histoire mais en même temps elle donne
aussi l'impression de vouloir faire
évoluer cette histoire est ce que là
elle est susceptible de parler à toute
la gauche j'ai quelques doutes on voit
bien qu'il ya une partie de la gauche
républicaine qui n'est pas prête en tout
cas aux inflexions qu'elle semble
suggérer dans son discours au nom de vos
choix de ce soir
je prendrai l'initiative
d'appeler les autres candidats
j'appellerais
j'appellerais yannick j'appellerais
fabien j'appellerais gens lui notre sort
appelle aujourd'hui l'union et le
rassemblement
alors je leur dirai avec l'esprit
je sais leur puissance mais je sais
aussi leur intelligence et leur sens de
l'intérêt général c'est le registre de
l'empathie c'est des registres de la
proximité c'est le registre de la
fraternité qu'elle essaye de stimuler a
appelé des gens par leur prénom ce s'est
montré qu'on est d'une certaine façon
dans une forme d'intimité avec eux et
que on a une histoire qui est une
histoire commune donc c'est la volonté
de montrer que elle n'est pas dans une
attitude qui est une attitude de
concurrence encore moins d'hostilité
mais qu'elle est dans une disposition
d'esprit qui vise d'abord à réunir
l'ensemble des sensibilités qui
s'incarne en effet dans un certain
nombre de leaders qu'elle connaît bien
contenu de sa grande expérience
politique et qu'elle vise à les réunir
autour d'un projet qu'on va et c'est
elle d'utiliser un registre il pas celui
de la concurrence mais plutôt celui en
effet je lui donne partout les relire
ces tunnels à volants et ce soir le
rejoindre au maire clos si forte qu un
serment nous promettons nous promettant
d'offrir à la france aux françaises aux
français des raisons de croire à nouveau
des raisons de rêver des raisons
d'espérer des réseaux d'imaginer
qu'ensemble la promesse républicaine
l'économie l'écologie solidaire que la
justice sociale que l'émancipation
individuelle que l'émancipation de la
jeunesse que la lutte contre toutes les
discriminations
que notre volonté de renforcer la
république en consolidant notre
démocratie nous voulons offrir aux
françaises et aux français des raisons
d'espérer de croire que tout cela se
mettra ensemble bien articulé pour
ouvrir enfin le chemin d'un avenir
désirable pour nos enfants
[Applaudissements]
et nourri leur espoir est nourri leurs
objectifs d'ailleurs elle accentue
beaucoup sur le pathos bienvenue sur le
logo 3 bien qu'elle ait déplu dans le
registre de l'émotion que dans le
registre d'une argumentation développée
qu'on prête rationnelle elle fait appel
d'une certaine façon à une mémoire très
affective de la gauche aujourd'hui les
conditions de la réussite de ce
dispositif très spécifiques et très
singulier que constitue la primaire
populaire ne sont pas les micros
éthiquement machiavel dit rien n'est
pire en politique les prophètes des
armées et à sa façon madame taubira est
un peu aujourd'hui une prophète désarmé
parce qu' elle n'a pas
les armes de la politique qu'elle entend
développer de la politique d'unité des
forces de gauche
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]